hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar floor 4 fundamentals for flow
cytometry i'm susie valdez of labrutz
and i will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific to learn
more visit them at thermofisher.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during this presentation to
do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
this webinar is educational and this
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain those credits
i'd now like to welcome our speaker
jolene bradford an associate director in
strategic collaborations at biosciences
division at thermo fisher scientific
julian welcome you may now begin your
presentation
great well thanks for the introduction
and i'm glad to have you all join me
today to explore the fundamentals of
fluorescence and flow cytometry
so thermo fisher is a world leader in
serving science and
have solutions to offer for the full
flow cytometry workflow
this is our agenda for today's
presentation
beginning with basics of fluorescence
briefly looking at the differences
between conventional and full spectrum
flow cytometry and then looking in
detail at different types of
fluorophores
so flow cytometry
works by passing thousands of cells per
second through a laser beam and then
capturing the light that emerges from
each cell as it passes through the
instrument
the ability to perform measurements on
single cells
thousands or even millions of cells in a
sample
makes flow cytometry one of the most
powerful platforms available today
most of
the measurements that come in flow
cytometry use fluorescent labels and the
main components are fluidics optics and
electronics
so here we see the electromagnetic
spectrum with visible wavelengths and
their corresponding colors highlighted
fluorophores generally emit within the
visible light portion of the spectrum
but we have been using the uv area for
decades which are the shorter
wavelengths and in more recent years the
near ir portion which are the longer
wavelengths
flow cytometry is dependent on the
control
collection and separation of light
there is an inverse relationship between
energy and wavelength
the shorter wavelengths of light will
have higher energy while the longer
wavelengths will have lower energy
so a fluorophore is a molecule that is
capable of fluorescein
in its ground state the fluorophore is
in a stable configuration and it does
not fluoresce
when light from an external source such
as a laser hits a flora 4
the molecule absorbs the light energy
when the energy is absorbed and is
sufficient
the molecule reaches a higher
energy state and this is called the
excited state
and the process is called excitation
and the next thing is the 404 will
rearrange itself from this
semi-stable excited state back to the
ground state
and with this excess energy is released
which is emitted back as light
and the emitted light is of a lower
energy and thus a longer wavelength than
the absorbed light
and this is a cyclic process and it
could be summarized as the excitation of
a fluorophore through the absorption of
light energy
a transient excited lifetime with some
loss of energy
and then return
of the fluorophore to its ground state
which is accompanied by the emission of
light
the stoke shift
is the term that's used to describe the
difference in wavelengths at which a
molecule emits light relative to the
wavelength at which it was excited or
the difference between the absorption
max and the emission max
so fluorophores absorb across a range of
wavelengths and this is called the
excitation range
they emit across a wave a range of
wavelengths as well and this is called
the emission range
within each of these ranges there is an
excitation maximum and an emission
maximum where the fluorescent molecule
maximally excite or maximally emit
because excitation and emission
wavelengths are different the absorbed
and admitted light are detected as
different colors
excitation and emission because it
occurs across this broad range of
wavelengths
the intensity may change so it's
important to understand that while the
illumination at the excitation max of
the fluorophore produces the greatest
fluorescence output illumination at
lower or higher wavelengths affects only
the intensity of the emitted light
and the range and overall shape of the
emission profile is unchanged
so it's useful to view the excitation
and emission curves to better understand
fluorophore properties and this includes
the full absorption and emission curves
not just the maximum so i have four that
are shown here
this information can be paired with your
instrument configuration to best
understand which fluorophores can be
detected and how to select compatible
dies
using a fluorescent spectre viewer here
we see the emission profiles of two
common dies alexa floor 488 and alexa
floor 647
with commonly used detector bandpass
filters
that are commonly used in conventional
compensation based
instruments
note that the fluorescence is only
collected within the range of the
bandpass filter and there's one floor of
four per one filter and so this means
that only a portion of the fluorescence
emission is collected
using a fluorescent spectra viewer we
see the emission profiles of these same
two dies but diagramming how the entire
or full emission profile is collected
using multiple detectors
and full spectrum flow cytometry uses
this information that is collected
from many detectors
across the emission range
so here's an example of the fitzy
fluorophore and here we see
the emission profile and here the the
conventional flow cytometry
we see only a section of the emission is
collected with
one filter
but with a full spectrum
multiple detectors are used to collect
the full fluorescence mission
so looking at example of alexa floor 647
and apc
when these are used together in a
conventional system it's just not
recommended because they are so close in
their emission
but when we look at the full spectrum
signature we can observe differences
between the two that are visible meaning
these two fluorophores might be unmixed
and you could potentially use them
together
intrinsic fluorophore brightness is an
important characteristic of each
fluorophore and
should be taken into consideration when
choosing fluorophores even for basic
panels
brightness depends on the capacity to
absorb energy which is called the
extinction coefficient and on the
ability to convert that energy into an
emitted signal and this is called the
quantum yield
it's important to understand your
instrument optical configuration and
characterize
compatible fluorophores
and then antigen density
or the expression of the target
molecules in your cells is also a major
consideration when choosing which
fluorophore
to pair with which antigen
so characterization of the instrument
being used
i mentioned is a critical component of
the experimental design and this needs
to be done on the specific
instrument and
model with lasers and detectors
that you are using so often it is useful
to compare results of the same target to
look at fluorescent intensity of the
different fluorophores
and this is typically done
with a cd4 clone of many fluorophores as
shown here and then you can get a
ranking of brightness levels
so now that we have reviewed the basics
let's start looking at a specific floor
4 information
we begin this with
fluorescent proteins and we are all
aware of the the very noble beginning of
fluorescent proteins
these are proteins that give off light
uh including chemilumiscent proteins
like luciferases as well as
fluorescent proteins like
gfp
so the the power lies in the clever ways
that scientists have adapted these for
use in the laboratory
so here we see gfp
this is a green fluorescent protein and
it has really led the way for use of
fluorescent proteins
uh the fluorochrome is inside a
barrel-like structure
and this structure makes the protein
very stable however gfp is sensitive to
alcohol fixation
where fluorescence is lost
with the rapid evolution of
protein technology
the utility of genetically encoded
fluorophores for a wide variety of
applications is just now being realized
and
fluorescent proteins have become one of
the most important tools in contemporary
research
so these are incorporated as protein
markers by infusing a fluorescent
protein gene to your target gene and the
host cell will then produce the target
protein
and the fluorescent marker permanently
attached so there's there is no need to
add a separate fluorescent dye to the
the sample
and when starting out
gfp is a really good choice
so here we see
an example
of
how gsp is being used
this can be done with transfected cell
lines transgenic animals animals
stable cell lines and even crispr
modified cell lines
using a variety of applications
this particular example we see u2 os
cells which have been transduced with a
dilution
of a
backman light reagent and you can see
the dilution series expressed by imaging
on the left and in flow cytometry we're
running those same samples and we can do
an overlay of the different fluorescence
readouts
fluorescent proteins
are typically classified by their
emission color
and
there's many different types of
fluorescent proteins
so this is
just a guide on
the colors and the wavelength ranges
recommendations for flow cytometry will
of course depend upon
the instrumentation you have to make
sure they have the proper
excitation and emission
optics
but these are some that have been used
in flow cytometry successfully
and if you're looking for resources to
look at fluorescent proteins in flow
cytometry
here are some websites that are
available and a very nice publication
in current protocols in cytometry
so some of the advantages there's just a
wide range of fluorescent protein
choices
they're very easy to work with they're
less perturbing to self-function
there are thousands of publications
useful across many platforms
and there may be
some
opportunity with a full spectrum flow
cytometry to exploit this
even further
some of the challenges include
loss of fluorescence upon fixation
their large size and variable brightness
they may produce autofluorescence in
some areas of the spectrum
and may require some non-standard lasers
or filter sets
most of the options involve molecular
biology transfection techniques
and a transfection efficiency is rarely
a hundred percent
so
uh and the final thing is if uh you are
using more than one fluorescent protein
in a flow cytometry experiment
we do require single color fluorescent
proteins
for
doing compensation
and or on mixing
so let's go on to the next class of
fluorescent proteins and these are the
fico billy proteins
this is another class derived from
phycobilly proteins found in algae and
plants and
these harvest flight
so
pe apc
and per cp are used
fairly extensive extensively in flow
cytometry and they are among some of the
brightest fluorescent molecules
available
so pe or phycoerythrin is a
fluorescence-based indicator of
cyanobacteria
it has a fairly large stokeship
stoke shift with extremely high emission
quantum yield
it's protected
by the covalent binding of the protein
backbone so the florence fluorescence is
not quenched
it's water soluble there's multiple
sites available for conjugation
then we have apc
and this is isolated from various
species of algae
this also has a very large stoke shift
and a very high quantum yield it's
protected
backbone and again water soluble and
stable for conjugation
and finally per cp
this again has a large stoke shift with
a high extinction coefficient
it is
highly water soluble
we do recommend a lower laser power
to avoid photo bleaching of per cp
and it is best used using a blue 48
excitation source
so some of the advantages are you know
these these fico billy proteins are very
bright with a high quantum yield they
are a standard fit for conventional flow
cytometers there's a large stoke shift
they're water soluble they're good
donors for tandem constructs and they
are available in a wide variety of
antibody conjugates
some of the challenges are that the
large size may limit some applications
they're quick to photobleach
they're used
mainly inflow cytometry
and
it may be more difficult to conjugate
than
organic reactive dyes
so now let's move on and talk about
small organic dyes
and as dye chemistry is continually
advantage advancing
there are really hundreds and hundreds
of dyes available
so here we see
organic dyes this is a broad class of
relatively small fluorescent compounds
some examples are fluorescein and
coumarin and their derivative
derivatives
the alexa floor dye series e floor dye
series body dyes
and we can go on and on
these small organic dyes are often based
around xanthine dyes and these molecules
contain at least
one conjugated double bond system in in
rings or chains or a combination of both
that is uh perturbed upon excitation
uh so naming of these dyes there's a
number of different conventions for
example here we see the alexa four dies
and these are named for the excitation
wavelength
and the e-floor dyes are instead named
for
the emission wavelength
so what makes a good dye and a good
probe
well from a chemist perspective
you're really looking at quantum yield
and extinction coefficient
but from a biologic
biobiologist perspective
you want to look at does it match the
system that you want to detect it in you
know lasers and detectors band passes
etc
can it be functionalized or conjugated
is it uh stable
uh in the environment and you know it
does it work within
standard
protocols
so
all of these things are looked at when
we're developing new dyes
and this does really require a
partnership between the chemist and the
biologists to develop
so advantages of
small organic dyes is these are
relatively stable there's lots of
excitation and emission profiles to
choose from
they're easy to conjugate they're very
good acceptor dyes for tandem constructs
very good for intracellular labeling
also good for imaging
applications in flow cytometry they're
available with a number of antibody
targets
they're easy to multiplex and they are a
good fit for both conventional and
spectral flow cytometry
some of the challenges uh there may be a
loss of signal with fixation
uh one of the
most uh important dyes fitzy uh is ph
sensitive so that's uh
information that's good to know
these typically have small stoke shift
with um asa asa symmetric hole emission
so now let's move on and talk about
nanocrystals
so the size of a q dot nanocrystal is in
the region of other proteins used for
cellular labeling such as gfp or
pe
but these particles fluoresce in a
completely different way than do
traditional fluorophores
so the q dot nanocrystals contain a
semiconductor material
which has been coated with additional
semiconductor shell
to improve optical properties of the
material
the nanocrystal core is about two to ten
nanometers in diameter
but it must be coded for it to
function properly in an aqueous
environment giving the particle a much
larger
size
so the core of the nanocrystal
determines its emission color
the shell improves bite brightness and
improves stability
hydrophilic hydrophobic coating also
provides stability
and then the ampliphyllic polymer gives
water solubility and then finally
there's a peg to reduce non-specific
interactions and provide reactive groups
for conjugation
so fundamentally acute nanocrystals are
fluorophores substances that absorb
photons of light
and re-emit photons at different
wavelengths
how they however they exhibit some
important differences
as compared to some of the traditional
fluorophores
these are
excited by every wavelength of light up
to its emission
and the emission from q dots is a very
narrow and symmetric
and because of the emission is so narrow
and symmetric the
overlap with other colors is minimal
redu
yielding less spillover or spread of
emission
uh the extinction coefficient shown here
on the y-axis is also an absolute
measure
of you know the we talked about the
ability to absorb light and you can
notice here
that the quantum dots
uh increase their absorbance
dramatically as you move into the violet
and uv regions
so advantages is these are
very bright with a high quantum yield
very photo stable large
stoke shift
and narrow emission peaks compatible
with standard workflows and these do
provide unique spectra that's useful for
spectral flow cytometry
some of the challenges are these large
size may limit applications and
currently these are best used for
surface labeling only
the broad excitation range may limit
use in conventional systems and there is
a limited antibody conjugates available
so now let's move on and talk about
tandem dyes
so when two
fluorophores are coupled together in
close association this creates a tandem
dye
they're bound by a covalent bond
and this is a process in which
a fluorescent molecule can be excited
and then transfer the energy to a nearby
fluorescent molecule which then emits
and this is
a fret
the donor and acceptor dyes have to be
in very close proximity
and the absorption of the acceptor must
overlap the fluorescence emission of the
donor
these are not naturally occurring
so
tandem dyes
are created to produce these molecules
with very long stoke shift
and so a fluorescent protein or a
polymer are used as the donor molecule
and small organic dyes are generally
used as acceptor molecules
and as the
excitation
excites the donor molecule and then it
emits a longer wavelength this emitted
energy from the donor excites the
acceptor molecule
and this creates emission at an even
longer wavelength
efficiencies of the tandem die is still
dependent on the efficiency of the
energy transfer
and while
fret energy is high
when fret energy is high we will see a
strong signal in the acceptor channel
and a very weak signal
in the donor channel
these were made to get more colors off
of a single laser enabling emissions
that are
given artificially to give you a longer
stoke shift
so examples of this are
a pe psi 7 molecule so this is combining
the fico urethran and the cyan and seven
together in a tandem construct
and you will be exciting the
pe molecule and gathering fluorescence
from the size seven
and here is an example of using apc
as the donor die and an alexa floor 750
a small molecule as the
acceptor die
and here is an example of using percy p
as the donor die and cyanine 5.5
as the
acceptor die
and as mentioned before percy p is best
used
using the 488 laser
so advantages of tandems are a long very
large stoke shift
this opens up regions of the spectrum
previously unavailable and gives us more
fluorophores to choose from
there are a variety and range of tandem
dyes
polymer dyes can also be used as a donor
and these are available in a wide
variety variety of antibody conjugates
some of the challenges is the large size
may limit applications
these are used mainly in flow cytometry
it can be more difficult to conjugate
than organic dyes
they are photosensitive so this does
mean
that we need to minimize exposure to
light
and
the storage
is critical both storage uh being
protected from light as well as
temperature
and there is
uh more lot to lot variation and
can be
you can also see cross laser excitation
so polymer dyes these are a different
type of
fluorophore and here we see super bright
436 and brilliant violet 421 as examples
of a general polymer format
we see
a polymer that consists of multiple
repeating fluorescent subunits that act
as a single fluorophore
these polymers absorb energy and convert
to an emitted signal with high
efficiency
and so this results in a very
bright signal
and any subunit can absorb the light and
then transmit the energy along the
backbone for release
these can also uh be used in a tandem
construct where the polymer acts as the
donor dye
and the energy transfers to an acceptor
die
so here we see uh super bright 436 and
bubb 421
base polymer die
being compared to the organic dye e
floor 450 these are all being
collected in the same detector of an
instrument
and uh looking
at the same target
so here we're looking at the uh scawan
apc as seen on the x-axis and on the
y-axis c kit conjugated to each of these
and then comparing the difference then
you can see that both the
super bright and brilliant violet uh
constructs are much brighter than the
e-floor the organic die
one thing that you do need to be aware
of with polymer dyes is if you are using
more than one in the same experiment
there can be polymer to polymer
interactions and this does require a
special staining buffer to mitigate
these interactions
and you can use either
a super bright complete staining buffer
or a brilliant staining buffer
to mitigate these
interactions
so some of the advantages is these are
just exceptionally bright fluorophores
so they're ideal for labeling low
abundance targets
it allows for the addition of
fluorophores in previously unused
spectral space
the tandems do have a large stokes shift
and just the use of these enable greater
multiplexing
and there is uh antibody conjugate uh
available
some of the challenges is that uh as i
mentioned they need a special buffer
when more than one uh polymer dye are
used together many of these are tandem
constructs so all of the
information around tandems apply to
these as well
if you're making a an antibody cocktail
it's recommended to use on the day of
use
and these are
validated for flow cytometry
applications
so a new type of foundational dye uses a
dna
scaffold so the phyton technology uses a
unique fluorescent dyes that are
engineered for excitation emission
brightness and stability
so small molecule dyes are precisely
positioned on single stranded dna
oligonucleotides
and then that this
self-assembles to form a remarkably
stable dna structure called the phyton
and the fluorophores are placed at
optimal distances
to optimize fret efficiencies
so different fluorophore choices allow
for a variety of excitation and emission
combinations
giving a number of unique spectral
signatures
and the brightness of the fluorescent
label can be modified by adding extra
fluorophores to the phyton arms
these are very stable at different
temperatures and with fixation
so here we see
two of these nova floor dyes as they're
called that use the phyton technology
and the naming convention is
the type of label is nova floor
and then the name of the primary
excitation laser is listed such as blue
here and then a number which corresponds
to
the maximum maximum of the emission
wavelength
so here we can see
example of how precise this fluorophore
design is and here we can see
differences of only 20 nanometers
which make these
very
useful in spectral flow cytometry
applications
as mentioned the nova floor dyes can be
engineered to have different levels of
brightness
within the same spectral signature
and this can be an advantage when
building large panels so that you can
you can pair either highly expressed
targets or low abundant targets within
the same spectral space
the cell blocks blocking buffer is
recommended to be used with all nova
floor conjugates when labeling cells for
the best background reduction
and the cell blocks buffer can also be
used with any fluorophore antibody
conjugate
as a an effective monocyte and
macrophage blocking solution
due to a phyton structure nova floor
dyes are not compatible with dna binding
dyes
but the noble floor dyes are compatible
with amine reactive viability dyes such
as the live dead fixable dead cell
stains
this is a new foundational technology
currently there are 19 unique
fluorophores
with
direct antibody conjugates and expanding
content
so the advantages of the nova floor dyes
include unique spectral signatures
minimal cross laser excitation
narrow emissions
and this allows for greater multiplexing
with reduced spillover spreading
and the range of brightness can be
paired with antigen densities for a
strategic panel design
it allows for additional
addition of fluorophores in previously
unused spectral space
and they are compatible with standard
workflows
some of the challenges
we do recommend the use of blocking
buffer
cannot be used with dna binding dyes
again if you're going to use antibody
cocktails it's recommended that
these are used on the same day of being
made
work is in progress for intracellular
protocols and these are validated for
flow cytometry applications
and finally let's take a look at some
functional probes
so there are many many
fluorescent probes that are used to
access cellular function
some bind specifically to cellular
molecules such as nucleic acids or
proteins or lipids
and these increase their fluorescence
others will accumulate selectively in
cell compartments
or maybe modify their properties through
some specific
biochemical reaction in response to
changes in the environment
such as a ph or membrane polarization
or
enzymatic activity
so this is uh showing just a short list
of these
so when considering using
some of these functional probes in flow
cytometry
all of the good practices of use of
instrument and panel design are still
required
but there are some additional things to
consider which i've highlighted in red
here
for example
what is the type of assay that you're
interested in
will you need to use living cells
or
do the cells need to be fixed for the
assay or can the cells be labeled
while living and then fixed
functional probes
generally require
extra
optimization
and
yes
single color controls are still needed
and all of the controls that you
normally would use are still needed
so here is an example of using one of
the
basic assays in flow cytometry
identification of dead cells
the most common definition definition of
dead cells is
inflow cytometry is when the plasma
membrane is compromised
and this can be exploited to identify
dead cells
the two common methods
one is using an impermanent dna binding
dye and this is for use with unfixed
cells
and then there is the amine reactive
dyes
which label unfixed cells but then can
be fixed after labeling
and here's another example
and so this really
provides an example of how knowledge
about this specific dye characteristics
is important when designing your
labeling approach
often called live cell dies these cell
permanent dyes have different
requirements that require optimization
on cell type
buffer composition
labeling temperature
labeling time
so it's really important when you're
looking at these functional dye probes
to understand uh some of these uh
different uh things and and
questions to ask
so uh the advantages are you know
there's a lot of different types of dyes
here from uv to intrava to infrared
you can do live cells to fix cells they
may be conjugated
there's a variety of different
applications
and these are compatible with many uh
platform forms including
flow cytometry imaging high content
analysis
and image cytometry
uh the challenges is that these can be
more difficult to multiplex due to the
differing labeling conditions
and the need to understand individual
probes to understand these
probe specific procedures and these do
require some optimization
so that brings us to the end of the
presentation and i'd like to open this
up now for questions
thank you so much jolene for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you
want to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
so let's take a look we already have
some great questions coming in jolene
our first question from an audience
member
you talked a bit about spectral flow and
i'm hearing it discussed more and more
what is the advantage of using spectral
and the second part of that question are
there
instruments that can do both traditional
flow and spectral flow
okay well um
great um
so full spectrum flow cytometry
also referred to as spectral flow you
know that it's a single cell technology
that captures and measures light
across this wide emission range for each
fluorophore present in the sample
collecting emissions for each floor for
across multiple ranges uh rather than
you know within a single band pass
and this creates the unique spectral
signature
uh that can facilitate different
differentiation of fluorophores with
comparable
emissions
and in turn this allows researchers to
increase the number of parameters in
their multi-color experiments using
many of the fluorophores that we have
today
and
they may be incompatible on a
conventional flow cytometer because of
the limitation of one fluorophore to one
detector
there are many conventional systems in
use today and
you know we are seeing
adoption of these new spectral systems
there are a few systems available now
that can accommodate both conventional
compensation-based
and spectrally unmixing
detection
thank you so much our next question why
do tandem dies need lot specific
compensation controls
uh sure so
to
accurately compensate or unmix
it's important to use the same
fluorophore used in the multi-color
sample as with the single color controls
and in fact to treat them identically as
the multi-color sample
because a photon transfer efficiency in
tandem pairs
can differ each time the conjugation is
performed
results can
vary from lot to lot
so each tandem
antibody lot
used in an experiment
it's recommended to use with its own
compensation or a mixing control to
ensure that the spare the spectral
characteristics
are identical
and uh things like uh you know tandem
dyes are very susceptible to damage from
things like light exposure
and
that can cause some variation so it's
best to use the specific tandem die
that
you are using for your single color
controls
you very much
now sometimes i see emission from the
donor die in my tandem does that mean
the tandem is decoupling
uh yeah so tandem dies have often been
described as degrading or decoupling
when describing
this
loss of emission from the
acceptor
and increase
emission by the donor
however you know tandem dyes are
covalently attached so the donor and
acceptor do not typically
come apart
um
still the the fret efficiency is never a
hundred percent which means that some
fluorescence in the donor detector is
expected
um there are potentially though several
causes that can
induce the loss of fret to the acceptor
light exposure is one of these it's also
called
photo bleaching
and this is due to the covalent bond is
being
affected
and
so it's always important to protect
tandem dyes from from light or other
sources of oxidative stress
also
exposure to freezing temperatures can
result to damage to the protein
based donor fluorophore
and a fixation can also affect uh the
tandem dye uh covalent bond quality
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
our next one what is the difference
between a tandem dye and a nova floor
dye
okay
so tandem dyes and the nova floor dyes
both use fret
where a donor die
is excited and the energy transfers to a
close by acceptor die
and the acceptor die is then um
admitting the fluorescence
tandem dyes have
two fluorescent molecules joined with a
covalent bond
different from this the nova floor dyes
use
small fluorescent molecules that are
precisely positioned on the
dna strand in the phyton structure
and the phyton is
this structure is very rigid
and it holds the two fluorescent
molecules at optimal distance for fret
so with the phyton structure
there is a no covalent bond to disrupt
thank you so much
now it can be difficult to get single fp
controls especially when using multiple
fps together is there any way to get
around this
yeah so
for accurate compensation or in mixing
a single color control is required and
this
includes single fluorescent protein
controls as well
there are some vendors that offer
fp-like beads
that these are you know modified
microspheres that are labeled with a dye
that is near identical
to match
specific fluorescent proteins
and now these work uh fairly well in
compensation-based systems
for spectral systems they may not be as
accurate for unmixing because there are
some slight difference in the
fluorescent emission from the actual fp
thank you now what is the size of a
bittorrent
yeah so
a phyton is
a
150 kilodaltons in size and it's
something like 20 nanometers across when
it's folded into its
formation
thank you and we have time for
two more questions
for those like me beginning to use
spectral flow can you offer some
suggestions on how to begin
yeah well there's uh many resources
available
you know i can
suggest you start with your local shared
resource laboratory staff
or instrument vendor
both of these can provide training and
assistance
for using their systems and running
experiments and
selecting
reagents
there are publication on panel design
and many informative webinars that are
available
many vendors also have a lot of
materials available on their websites to
help
things like fluorescents spec reviewers
and panel builder tools can be very
valuable
another publication that i can call out
specifically is the omip omip
which stands for optimized multi-color
immuno phenotyping panels
so these are publications with validated
panels that have been uh
useful in flow cytometry and there's um
you know
up to 80 or 70 different panels that
have been published and shown to work
very well
you might start with a modest panel at
first and as you gain experience you
know maybe grow to larger panels
thank you so much julian we have time
for one more question
this audience member says could you talk
a little bit about the type of reagents
used with the scitos systems
um yeah so um
the scytof
technology i mean it's also called mass
cytometry
it is similar to a flow cytometry
but i didn't talk about these systems
today because they are not fluorescence
based
this uses an
a single cell
single cells are in suspension with this
technology
and
they're labeled with metal tagged
reagents that use a
stable isotopes that are not normally
found in biological systems
but they are detected using
like a high resolution mass
spectrometry system
so there's many similarities between the
scitev technology and flow cytometry but
it does not use fluorescence
building i want to thank you for your
time today and for your work
i also want to take the time to thank
lab roots and our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast and before we go i
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand labrets
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone stay
safe bye